foreign
[Music]
it is the courage and the determination
of the party leaders and the people of
Northern Ireland who have been Central
in making this opportunity for peace
happen it's been reached because
everybody was willing to compromise
everybody has moved a little and as a
result everyone can be a winner as a
result of this agreement
Europe has in particular shown how all
bloody conflicts can be transcended
through new Partnerships
I am European as well as Irish
and what we all have to learn is what
the peoples of Europe learned and we are
learning in Northern Ireland difference
whether it's your race or your religion
or your nationality is an accident of
birth
and it's not something we should be
engaged in Conflict about it's something
we should respect
[Music]
I think the Good Friday agreement is the
basic underpinning of of the peace that
we all enjoy I think it's made a big
change I think it has made a difference
if it was to go away they're probably it
might be a difference and it might go
back to like what it was which is quite
scary
[Music]
we'll just need to move forward and make
sure history doesn't repeat itself and
it's sort of a foundation for how to
move forward as well
[Music]
thank you